Grafica este sistema de ecuaciones e identifica
el número de soluciones que tiene.
Y aquí nos dan un sistema de ecuaciones,
el cual tenemos que graficar
y pensar acerca de sus soluciones.
Esta primera ecuación la voy a reescribir nuevamente en el mismo color en el que la voy a graficar,
ya está en la forma pendiente-ordenada,
"y" igual a "3x" más 1, podemos ver entonces
que la pendiente es igual a 3
y la ordenada al origen...
la ordenada es igual a 1, esta es la pendiente,
la he llamado "m",
pues en muchos textos la ecuación de
la recta la escriben como "y" igual a "mx" más "b".
Vamos a graficarla, la ordenada al origen
es el punto 0, 1,
vamos a ubicarlo, 0, 1...
aquí tenemos el eje "y"
y este de aquí es el eje "x"
y ahora la pendiente es igual a 3,
quiere decir que si nos movemos en 1
en la dirección positiva de las "x"
vamos a movernos en 3 hacia arriba,
si avanzamos 2 hacia la derecha, vamos a subir 6...
2, 4, 6... 6 entre 2 es igual a 3, se conserva
el valor de la pendiente, lo mismo pasaría
si nos movemos en 1 en la dirección negativa
de "x", nos moveríamos 3 en la dirección
negativa de "y", -3 entre -1, sigue siendo
igual a 3, si nos movemos -2 en "x",
nos moveremos -6 en "y"...
-1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
ahora podemos unir los puntos para tener la
gráfica de esta recta...
unimos estos puntos...
lo voy a hacer lo mejor posible...
aquí tenemos la recta...
bueno... no, no está muy recta...
déjame hacerla mejor...
aquí tenemos...
unimos los puntos...
¡uy!
no sé qué pasó, hoy mi mano está muy temblorosa...
vamos a intentarlo, nuestro mejor intento...
último intento...
ahí la tenemos, no está tan mal...
ésta es esta recta,
"y" igual a "3x" más 1.
Grafiquemos ahora la segunda ecuación.
La segunda ecuación la voy a reescribir aquí,
"2y" más 4 igual a "6x" y la quiero llevar
a la forma pendiente-ordenada, a la forma
"y" igual a "mx" más "b",
para esto lo que hacemos es...
vamos a restarle 4 a ambos lados de la ecuación,
así es que restamos 4 del lado izquierdo
y restamos 4 del lado derecho,
el lado izquierdo nos queda,
"2y" es igual a "6x" menos 4,
ahora para despejar "y" vamos a dividir
entre 2 ambos lados de la ecuación.
Dividimos entonces entre 2 el lado izquierdo
y entre 2 los términos del lado derecho,
ahora la ecuación resulta,
"y" igual a "3x" menos 2...
"y" igual a "3x" menos 2 y ya tenemos esta
segunda ecuación en la forma pendiente-ordenada.
Grafiquemos ahora esta recta.
Tenemos una ordenada al origen de -2,
ubicamos el punto 0, -2 y la pendiente es 3,
observa que es la misma pendiente de aquí,
tienen la misma inclinación estas dos rectas,
si avanzamos 1 a la derecha, subimos 3,
avanzamos 1 a la derecha subimos otros 3,
avanzamos 1 a la derecha subimos otros 3...
y lo mismo si nos vamos hacia la izquierda,
1 a la izquierda, 3 abajo, 1 a la izquierda, 3 abajo,
aquí tenemos algunos puntos de la segunda recta...
Unimos estos puntos
para obtener la recta...
voy a hacerlo lo mejor posible
para que sea recta...
Ya la tenemos,
ahí tenemos esa segunda recta,
la cual llevamos primero a su forma punto pendiente
y luego la graficamos.
Ahora, hicimos todo esto para identificar
el número de soluciones
que tiene este sistema de ecuaciones,
pero la solución de un sistema
de ecuaciones es una pareja de valores "x" y "y"
que satisfacen ambas ecuaciones.
Ahora, si hubiera un valor de "x" y "y" que
cumpliera con este sistema de ecuaciones,
entonces ese valor de "x" y "y"
tendría que ubicarse en las dos gráficas,
pues esta recta en azul son todas las parejas de "x" y "y"
que cumplen con esta primera ecuación,
la recta roja son todas las parejas "x" y "y"
que cumplen con la segunda ecuación,
si una pareja cumple con ambas ecuaciones,
tiene que ubicarse en las dos rectas,
pero al ver las gráficas vemos que son dos rectas paralelas, dos rectas que nunca se intersectan,
no existe un punto de intersección,
no hay una pareja de valores "x" y "y"
que cumpla con ambas ecuaciones.
Entonces no se intersectan...
no intersección...
por lo tanto,
no hay solución a este sistema de ecuaciones.
Esto implica entonces que no hay solución...
no solución...
Sabemos eso porque estas dos rectas no se intersectan y quizás no necesitas graficar para saber eso.
Te están dando dos rectas distintas,
pues tienes dos ordenada al origen distintas,
sin embargo tienen la misma pendiente,
son rectas paralelas,
son rectas que nunca se intersectan
y como esas rectas son la representación gráfica
de cada una de las ecuaciones del el sistema,
el sistema no tiene solución.